aujourd'hui je vous présente mon plan de
travail alors qu'il vient à peine de
dévoiler ces 7 priorités pour le réseau
de l'éducation le ministre Bernard
drinville est rattrapé par la réalité
des couloirs d'écoles selon des données
obtenues par ces adversaires libéraux
les codes violences rapportées dans
certains centres de services scolaire
sont passés du simple au double en
l'espace de 4 ans s'il faut en faire
plus je vous le dis on va en faire plus
et puis pas juste dans les cas de
violence d'élèves à élèves je suis très
préoccupé aussi par les cas de violence
envers le personnel scolaire au centre
de services scolaire de la bosse
Etchemins les casses sont passés
d'environ 400 par année à tout près de
1000 aux affluents dans la naudière ils
sont passés de 757 à plus de 2000 et aux
1000 dans les Basses Laurentides le
nombre passe de 2500 à plus de 4000
qu'est-ce que c'est donner là nous
préoccupent la réponse c'est oui ça nous
a toujours préoccupé pour le bien-être
de nos jeunes mais aussi pour notre
personnel
le centre des milliers l'invite
toutefois à la prudence car ici tous les
cas grave ou non sont corrigés ce qui
n'est pas le cas partout au Québec
l'augmentation de la clientèle scolaire
explique peut-être en partie la hausse
et les élèves dénoncent peut-être plus
qu'avant la pandémie semble aussi avoir
exacerbé certains comportements ce qu'on
entend beaucoup c'est que les élèves
n'ont plus beaucoup de tolérance on est
à fleur de peau on explose rapidement ça
dégénéré dans nos écoles inquiète la
députée libérale marouarisky veut que
l'Assemblée nationale aille au fond des
choses avec un mandat d'initiative qui
permettrait d'étudier la problématique
en commission parlementaire le caractère
des gestes posés et vraiment à
glace frapper un jeune à coup de marteau
année un couteau à l’école à une arme à
feu à l'école c'est du jamais vu je
voudrais pas que s'installe madame la
Présidente cette idée que d'envoyer
notre enfant à l'école c'est de le
mettre en danger s'il vous plaît un peu
de responsabilité dans ce dossier là
pour que la question soit étudiée en
commission parlementaire la CAQ devra
donner son accord mais pour l'instant le
ministre de Rainville refuse de dire si
les favorable à cette demande des
libéraux ici alexandre Duval
Radio-Canada Québec